The Joe Rogan Experience what you did in
the Olympics with a broken neck is just
nothing short of insane yeah how did you
do that I didn't have a choice I mean
what happened was I got thrown on my
head uh in the first round up close to
you there you go what happened was I got
thrown on my head the first round of the
Olympic trials and I broke my neck and I
didn't know it so I kept wrestling my
arms were numb and and my neck was in
excruciating pain and I wrestled through
the semis and won and then I had to go
on to the finals and wrestle and I want
one there so I won the first round of
Liberty trials with my neck broken I
went home the next day and I went to my
doctor and he took an MRI of my neck he
said you have four discs or four broken
vertebrae and two discs sticking
directly in her spinal cord he said you
can't wrestle anymore you're done and I
was devastated man I I didn't know what
to do I I figured I'd better get a
second opinion so I I went to another
doctor and he said basically the same
thing but he said when is the next round
of the trials I said six weeks he said
you know what I might be able to get you
ready by then I said what's your plan he
said well we're gonna we're not you're
not gonna be able to train much you're
not gonna you're gonna have to let your
neck rest and heal for the next six
weeks and it won't be completely healed
but it'll be healed enough that you can
still go and what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna have a doctor travel with you and
this doctor is going to stick you with
12 shots of Novocaine in your neck five
minutes before each one of your matches
he said therefore you won't feel the
pain you'll forget your neck is broken
and you'll wrestle more freely but but
he said I'm warning you an hour after
your matches are over you're going to be
in excruciating pain from the abuse your
neck takes during those matches and he
said are you okay with this and I said
yes and it worked wow what a decision to
make yeah I didn't have a choice I mean
it was no guarantee I was going to make
the Olympic team in 2000 or 2004. this
is my one time this is my one shot
imagine those guys you beat yeah
realizing a guy with a [__] broken
neck just kicked my ass I never thought
about that like not only did he beat me
not only did he win he won with a broken
neck
amazing yeah so I went to the Olympics
and we did the same thing there wow and
I was able to get through it and that's
when I retired and I retired for a few
years and that was out did it heal up a
hundred percent or is it always been
[__] with you since then
um I always had problems with it you
know especially my um my motor skills in
my hands
um I broke my neck four more times in
the WWE and it got worse and worse I
mean I have nerve damage in my neck I
don't have I lost three inches in both
arms and my uh the atrophied because uh
my neck was just so messed up and I've
had five surgeries and none of them have
really worked uh I'm gonna end up having
half Fusion which will be down the line
have you done stem cells I tried it
didn't work it didn't do it Where'd you
go I went to
um South America
um I forget which uh which country I
can't remember Columbia yeah Columbia
yeah did you go to bioaccelerator did
you yes I did yes I did a lot a lot of
athletes a lot of Fighters go down there
yeah it didn't work for me so much
damage huh yeah yeah just too much I
wonder if you just kept going
so what's the extent of it now like
um I you know what I I can't feel my
pinky fingers
um you know I have a lot of atrophy in
my arms I don't have a lot of strength I
can curl for like 20 pound dumbbells uh
when I do uh triceps I can only push the
weights about 60 pounds forward it's
just I don't have a lot of strength in
my upper body and uh so
um the thing is I all right I if you
look at my chest right here you'll see
there's a dip here yeah okay that that's
for my neck that's a nerve that died and
no longer had this muscle in my chest I
have a complete Ripple through my chest
it'll never come back and I'm afraid
it's going to happen again so I'm going
to have to have Fusion sooner than later
because if I don't the damage is going
to get worse and worse and then you know
my arms are going to end up just
shrinking to nothing have you looked
into replacement discs yeah no but you
know what I just got uh an email from
doctor in New York and he told me he was
doing it and so I'm going to call him in
this next couple weeks to see if we can
set up an appointment Al Jermaine
Sterling the former UFC banway champion
he injured his neck really badly and
then got fouled in a title fight
um actually it was a very controversial
because uh pyoto yawn the Russian cat
who hit him with a knee to the head
while he was down lost his title that
way so he lost his titles because even
though Al Jermaine's a sensational
fighter everybody was giving him [__]
because he won the title because of that
so then he goes and gets a disc replaced
in his neck defends the title and
dominates Peoria Yan in the rematch
beats him in the rematch and then goes
on to defend the title A couple more
times and then just lost it to Sugar
Shawn O'Malley but he's got an
artificial disconnected yeah he worked
and he's good he's good to go now I need
to look into that titanium it's a
titanium articulating disc so instead of
fusing to disc this Titan see if you can
find it online Jamie articulating
titanium disc replacement for spinal
vertebrae uh cervical I think
um so Eddie Bravo has one in his lower
back too
and they so they do lower backs too yeah
they do lower backs and what they do is
they this is what it looks like so they
they instead of fusing your discs which
the problem with fusing your vertebrae
is you no longer have any movement with
this it allows you to have movement and
uh I think it lasts for a long [__]
time you know it's crazy I had a doctor
when I broke my neck the second time he
wanted me to do fusion and he told me
that you know he's gonna have to do
three levels and then I'd have to retire
and I was like well that might not be an
option it was the same doctor that Stone
Cold Steve Austin had and Steve still
has problems to this day with the fusion
everybody I know that had Fusion has
real problems yeah I see that's why I'm
nervous about getting it and that's why
I'm glad I found this doctor in New York
City that can do it I I didn't know it
was like there there was no there was a
doctor out there that could do that kind
of stuff